en avec un but d'avancé on aura le temps
de bien ouvrir de bien nourrir le chat
et tout ça pour le stream ce soir et
comme je sais pas trop quoi faire parce
qu'on a passé beaucoup de temps avec le
ca cadre mal je vais je vais bien je
vais bien recadrer justement c'est un
peu l'avantagé d'arriver bien en avance
c'est qu'on a bien le temps de bien
cadrer et ouais donc et en plus on n'a
pas le bon truc on est en mode title
tuset à la console est en mode comme ça
parce que je pensais il ya un truc qui
n'allait pas et aucun recadrer début et
on va tout doucement commencer dans quoi
elle gémit dans le titre je sais pas
trop quoi faire ce soir
il ya le championnat du monde de
championne de rapides de deux parties
longues qui vient de deux parties blitz
de parties rapides absolument de parties
rapides donc ni vis ni longue mais un
lien inverse qui vient de ceux de se
terminer donc ok j'ai compris pourquoi
ça marchait pas nous allons régler son
époque et donc on est bon donc la
semaine et on avait fait des parties
avec vous je sais que ça vous avez plus
donc on peut éventuellement soir partir
là dedans savoir ce que vous écrivez sur
le chat mais soit on peut repartir là
dedans donc dans les parts des partis
avec avec les personnes qui regardent
soit je peux essayer de faire des blitz
en vous promettant un sur le niveau
parce que 21 heures de live en trois
jours j'ai envie de vous dire là bien
jouer aux échecs c'est pas c'est pas
trop le truc qu'on va réussir à faire
mais on peut on peut faire là on peut
faire l'autre notre côté ce que je
pensais si on fait des parties avec vous
c'est que
marc et en super fatigué vous aurez pas
mal de chances de gagner jusqu'à 10 fois
ça va être un massacre
la dernière fois
la dernière fois vous en aviez vous et
vous n'avez même pas fait une mule en
fait la dernière fois vous n'avez vous
n'avez pas fait nul vous étiez en pls
total vous avez tout perdu
j'étais un peu déçu pour vous et du coup
c'est vrai que là peut-être aujourd'hui
c'est le bonjour ça peut être le bon
jour donc on peut refaire partie avec
vous si ça vous fait kiffer et dans ce
cas faut que vous me défier et c'est
vrai que oui aujourd'hui vous avez je
pense nous devrions prendre au moins une
passe que j'ai vraiment du mal à voir
les trucs en un coup donc on commence
contre hikaru kama sutra sarokin calcul
plus donc le cap des 5 hockey me faire
un sacrifice pour mettre le volume de
des coûts moi quand on va essayer de
jouer une finale aller même si vision
pro f 3 était probablement meilleur j'ai
envie de jouer ma petite finale quoique
puis en première trois dames pro f 3
peut-être bien fait bon j'en sais rien
mais bon e3 je rends le pion je rentre
dans la petite finale ok il ne veut pas
il ne veut pas jouer petite finale
écoutons va prendre là on va faire ses 6
ok je veux jouer la finale maroc et j'ai
rien compris j'ai absolument rien
compris aux derniers coups de cette
partie on écoute on va faire le beau jeu
on va les prendre le pion ces deux quand
même parce que c'est un pion qui traîne
il fait cavalier c'est rond va faire
c'est si sûr va couper les oreilles
donc on va faire réussissent pour
empêcher de perdre le pion à vii on va
faire ses six pour solidifier et on va
se jouer une petite structure karo kann
avec deux pions plus en finale ce qui à
mon avis assez sympa ok on va faire un
échec
ça fait pas de mal on va développer le
cavale mais pas mal d'influencés six ans
cette structure que bien le cavalier bon
ok bon cavalier b17 vraiment je dois
vous avouer que je comprends pas trop
les coudes et blanc
on va chasser et je vais prendre le four
set on a joué solide comme juge beaucoup
de mal à calculer on va essayer juste de
jouer positionnelle en train de faire
semine importe quoi en voulant pas
compliquer la position va continuer à
échanger des pièces
chaque pièce est changé nous rapprochant
inexorablement de la victoire j'ai envie
de dire non on va essayer d'échanger les
tours au prochain comme ça on va rester
on va rentrer dans une finale de pièces
mineurs donc on peut peut-être faire
tour des huit quoi qu'on peut faire fou
prend tour à 8,3 et fuit 3 au 7 e tour
des huit comme ça on va chasser comme ça
graduellement donc s'en va chasser
graduellement la tour peut pas rentrer
en septième et un cavalier qui couvrent
on a récupéré la colonne ouverte
ok il peut échanger les tours éventuelle
vie dame en mai mais ça nous rapproche
encore la victoire un moyen de pièces
sur l'échiquier plus nos deux pions vont
parler c'est l'idée depuis du talent
c'est d'échanger au maximum et en bout
de course et va rester avec de plus en
plus donc deux dames potentiellement on
va continuer à les changer maintenant on
va échanger des pions maintenant on veut
faire kf4 pour échanger le fou
s'approcher du pion cavaliers un peu
loin puisqu'il en diagonale le quart
aller choper celui-là en g2 une phase on
est heureux de gratter des pions
m le cavalier ici
alors
on va jouer comme ça on va approcher le
roi qui va faire froid prend ici comme
ça il va prendre là et nous on va
prendre là et là ça jaillit la plus de
pions on aura fait le ménage et
maintenant on va envoyer le nôtre comme
on contrôle les cases f3 et elle fin
avec le cavalier on va pouvoir l'envoyer
on peut tout près moules en fait ça sans
il peut pas l'arrêter comme ça on en
passe un premier et puis après on n'en
passera un deuxième site avec celui-là
on va récupérer le fou est avec celui là
on va faire la dame a ils nous arrêtent
parce qu'ils apprennent ou plus
intelligemment que nous mais on avait
notre pions et la très honnêtement j'ai
du mal à comprendre l'intérêt de jouer
cette position et notre adversaire a
rebondit donc ok on a réussi à gagner la
première on a réussi à gagner la
première c'est déjà pas mal
donc les autres les autres alésien vous
pouvez me vous pouvez me défier doukhan
challenge me plaît aussi en anglais pour
les pour les gens qui regardent en en
anglais on n'a pas lu groucha pendant le
pendant le championnat du monde de
rapides ne l'a pas vu peut-être il ya un
autre pseudo dans le rsa il ya des
histoires de pseudo youtube les pseudos
machin pas toujours évident
donc t'as pas fait t'as pas joué très
intelligemment à l'ouverture est
effectivement effectivement
effectivement je ne te cache pas que je
pense la même chose donc les défilements
arriver petit à petit je sais que
l'enfant n'a eu pas mal de défis donc on
joue contre steak steak bonne chance à
stec
donc on joue en 3 plus de cette partie
elle capte est un problème de connexion
dans ça va allez allez on va jouer le
beau jeu il va apprendre à faire c'est
ci sera jouée le beau jeu
donnez des pions on va essayer
d'attaquer comme des brutes
on va essayer on va attaquer comme des
brutes nous sommes des brutes nous
sommes des brutales et les bruits
allaient les brutes on va vraiment
laissé le pion va pas nous n'allons pas
protéger protéger le pion ne nous
intéresse pas nick s'appelle le gland
vie blackburn pour l'acteur des grands
championnats d'angleterre tu joues au
foot moi il prend pas le pion pour le
moment on va reculer on va essayer de
jouer dans l'esprit à la partie saluer
le tribord bourgeoisie j'étais assez
occupé ces derniers temps tu n'as pas le
droit attention la police vitrine va
venir t'arrêter l'intention si tu
continues comme ça
candy bur noir bien vu julien vu 20 20
sur l'instant que le steak à de gros
problèmes avec sa connexion internet
malheureusement pour lui il ne pas
prendre le pion je pense qu'on est
obligé de reprendre ce pion mais alors
je pense qu'on va faire g5 très
rapidement je pense dans envie de jouer
cette partie dans l'esprit donc et
finalement il le prend on va on va jouer
à la bourre très risqué évidemment mais
bon on nous a dit que ça ap les burnes
noirceux cette ouverture du bureau de
noir ça donne quand même envie d'envoyer
de plongée quoi bon tant qu envoyé deux
pions j'écoutais on va voir ce que ça
donne mais j'ai pas j'aime pas du coup
ce truc fou aux fauves et cinq français
si ce qu'il a fait parce que du coup ça
me ça lui fait perdre du temps et ça me
ça me permet d' un peu plus souligné les
problèmes sur cette diagonale en fait
j'ai pas trop aimé cette manière de
jouer
après c'est pas la science infuse mais
ça me paraît ça me paraît pas taper à
bouger la dame j'aime être là d'amendé 5
et je vais commencer attaques qu'ils
n'aillent et de plongée de avec la dame
sera plus intéressant que de prendre
avec l'as tournehem
ça a créé plus de menaces ça m'a l'air
pas mal
vendée groupe de connectique c'est bon
pour les autres n'hésitez pas si vous
êtes dans le chat et il fait partie avec
les amener à même avec tout le monde
parti avec tout le monde
n'importe qui tout le monde peut jouer
mais qu'ils avaient pensé si je vais me
faire dame des symboles ya la dame en
prise il ya ça en prise il ya ça emprise
il ya pas mal de trucs emprise en plus
comme juste et si vous voulez me battre
pour une fois là c'est vraiment le jour
là c'est le goût des pour me battre
parce que quand même 20 20 20 heures de
live en en trois jours j'ai l'impression
que j'ai le cerveau est en bouillie
la pression c'est une compote sans une
compote de pommes d'ailleurs tiens mon
cerveau est une compote de pommes ce
n'est pas une compotée d'abricots fait
très attention
alors on va venir par là on va re
menaces et mat
voilà du coup c'est la dame qui tombe on
va les mater comment comme ça à
l'étouffée qu'on peut aller tout faire
très attention
ok bah on va prendre les prochains défis
on a 20 20 a les vingt toiles titouan
initiale et une grotte allez hop là grob
on va voir s'il suit vraiment la chaîne
parvint à y suis pas du coup j'ai
préparé des quatre mais pas forcément je
cherche des antilles doit qu aux
morsures de komodo que je que je laisse
dire que je donne aux auditeurs sur la
chaîne le problème c'est qu'à sur dame
g7 il faut et fils aymon plongée me
bloque la matière je fais j'ai cinq
fautes intéressant g5
je veux faire dame prend g7 mais je
n'aurai plus de problèmes
et du coup il va faire les pistes je
vais premi
- tours j'ai un jeu très heureux très
heureux de ce début de partie des
regards très original d'alger 5 à un
nombre non alors cette drogue ça passe
pas super bien
ça respire pas la joie la grob là pour
le moment est bon on va faire payer 5 et
on va reprendre avec la dame et on va
essayer d'aller menacer d'aller taquiner
la casbah huit essais de grauby fier ok
on ils échangent la finale ça nous fait
plaise vu la poubelle monstrueuse qu'on
a depuis le début et on va jouer trois
cg66 libère un peu ces pièces logique
qu'elles le font eux deux pour le moment
les retours g5
l'originalité de la grotte je viens de
tous les côtés je suis là je sais tu es
là non je suis la fpt
ok mais on va prendre prendre et prendre
nous grauby fion l'adversaire maintenant
on va s'en prendre à lui donc et pas
vraiment il protège on a monté le roi
j'avais une malle de monter le roi en
finale donc on monte à la volée
j'avais pas mal on va faire c'est que
ces cinq et on va monter monter monter
vous c4 et toute la bonne compagnie et
les tours on prend le cas tu regardes le
clouage en échange tout aussi sot
prochain et on rentre dans la finale
deux pions avec deux pions plus donc
très simple à gagner on a on a réussi à
gros billets alors on va jouer allez on
va jouer contre maxime pissas pizarro
glow un pissarro glow très intéressant
comme non j'aime beaucoup pizarro glos
je serais content du nom
bien joué maman tu aurais dû des gros
vivier après g4 g5 tu t'es laissé groupe
b t'aurais dû des gros billets la dgre
hobby fication pour nos éditeurs espagne
terme très important des échecs gros
biffi castioni des gourbis fication c4
et ont gagné sans du coup on s'y fait b5
soir avoir vu des six faits - sens on
verra comment on développe
envie de faire un petit coup de à 4
quand même fort de voir un peu ce que ça
donne vous allez mettre son pion en c6
je sais pas j'ai l'impression que des
fois 6
aujourd'hui de prendre au moins ont
détruit un peu la structure est
maintenant cavale de deux cas valls et 6
en fait j'aurais joué ces six pour
protéger avec un pion parce que là il a
les pions isoler le cavalier qui revit
en c3 qui réattaque ralph ou hilare
perdre un tempo ym a ouvert la colonne
j'aurais vraiment ni plutôt le pion ans
et 6 bat je peux pas montré mais pour
jouer plus solide et sûr fois si
j'aurais de la tactique à base de tout
reprendre cavaliers prendre un à quatre
échecs et dame prend à cisco lance pas
de la grande tactique et quand même
auxquelles il consolide
il a raison améliorer 20 il serait mieux
avec le pion qua non c'est pas kata
encore pour l'adversaire d'affaires fou
de rock cgc g5 dans l'esprit à fond mais
le foin f2 comme ça on cache le fou j'ai
enchaîné paru 5 et prend ses cartes je
pense
pas sûr que ce soit mieux mais j'ai bien
envie de récupérer bon piont quand même
au bout d'un moment ça me saoule je ne
fous qui protège bien je vois même faire
re 6 à la rigueur mais mangent pas envie
d'ouvrir le fou grand mangeur on va
faire simple
peut-être qu'on peut gratter ce mec là
et puis venir jouer sur ses faiblesses
la portant de comprendre un peu la
logique comment on reconnaisse que la
maintenant que la plus fous de cases
blanches
ok mais je vais prendre ici une fois il
va apprendre et je vais venir en trois
comme ça je re contrôle un peu ça et
sage contrôle un peu le cas balle et je
viens voir vers f5 donc et on va
replacer les pièces maintenant donc soit
fou et 4 pour chasser la tour soit en
recul avec le foulon place la dame
devant avoir peut-être même dame deux
cavaliers f5 et machin
ils couvrent des cases
envie de faire dame de coûts flexible je
lis les tours je menaçais dufour en
bessin quinze jours ok ça c'est dans
l'esprit à fond quand la tour en c1
colonnes ouverte un temps qui rockent
pas je vais pas aller me jeter mumbai
sida mme lacasse g4 on va la prendre
mais bon giro dans la case of saint des
saints que rsa c'était peut-être très
mauvais ça c'était débile on reste très
bien cependant mais ce n'était pas utile
c'était ni utile ni indispensable
on va coller comme une tour en c6
on reste bien parce que son roi il est
très mal en fait cette mais bon
peut-être un petit coup de fouet à un
fou des deux suites pour aller choper
puis longé 5 ça aussi c'est important à
voir les petits coups de replacements
comme ça en place les pièces mais il
faut en d2 il va échanger une paire de
tours on va reprendre du fou en plus on
va pouvoir les taper on va les pouvoirs
à l'état pg5 là-bas en tranquillement ok
ça c'est cool
ce qu'on tape le pion g5 et on va
pouvoir coller la tour en des 8 tu
restes ici on peut même faire pions
prendra prend des 6 et puis on prend g7
qui devrait passer où on fait le beau
jeu à fond les beaux jeux a conseillé de
prendre là on prend là derrière on
regrette un pion et on va tout faire
péter refait alors attendez jusqu'à
c'est justement le problème que j'ai
aujourd'hui ce que miles a du mal a
calculé que j'ai bien envie de faire un
échec comme ça pour commencer
truc c'est que j'ai envie de faire du
beau jeu aussi toujours vous me
connaissez kim est peut-être le beau jeu
c'est juste de prendre qu'elle s'y
reprendre la dame on encaisse le cavale
puis à la tour en prix s'y prend et
voilà et s'ils prenaient du roi je pense
qu'il devait avoir un réseau avec quidam
g6 et dames quelque chose mais bon là au
moins on récupère encore une pièce donc
on reprend l'avantagé matériel et on va
lui coller un petit d'amd vite matt des
familles et s'il avait joué roi prend
complètement écrasant mais aux échecs se
retrouver le mat je sais pas exactement
je vois par le soit pas le match quoi
c'est un truc comme ça déjà c'est pas
mal ou même jusqu'aux les influents aux
quatre ça doit suffire mais peut-être
quelque chose de plus en plus incisif
comme cela en fait c'est quasiment grecs
peuvent faire car il s'attaque aux deux
dames mater 20 ans gros tas quasi pas de
coût mais peut-être quelque chose de
plus de plus méchant les contrôles
tribord
alors j'ai plein de défis en cours mais
je peux pas accepter les défis tout et
on va faire 1 5
d'un côté le cadre des 5 et de ce côté
là on fait comme ça ça donne un pion
mais on a de l'activité à sortir les
pièces à fond à faire le grand roque on
va attaquer bon voila j'ai envie de dire
on va prendre les 30 premiers prend h2
et prendre d une dame de plus mais ok
c'est pas tout à fait fini cette
histoire parce qu'il ya un peu de
matériel contre la dame mais bon
étonnant envoyer notre adversaire 1700
ou le tribord bons joueurs et voyez où
je les trucs qui sortent un peu du
commun qui sont un peu offensif f
on dit quoi avec les noir sans avoir
rien fait d'exceptionnel si on regardait
les courses c'est que des coûts de
développement enfin j'ai squale j'ai
sorti mes deux cas mais sorti mon fou
madame grand roque et j'ai juste
encaissé la dame enfin j'ai rien fait
d'exceptionnel donner un petit échec ça
nous fera gagner du temps
ok maintenant lafarge et 5 juste et
jouer sur le clouage
mais s'il avait juste à temps sont durs
comme dirait fab si déjà vous faites
gaffe que vous donnez pas de pièces en
un coût et que vous jouez un peu
offensif avec l'initiative ça peut le
faire
alors venez on va gagner au prochain
coup on aura la dame de plus on sera bon
ben beau monde au high yield antonsson
french bataille tactique soyez contents
allez on va même sans faire une autre
une petite autres allez hop
faites vous la main les mecs c'est
simple les échecs des codes et double
attaque des découvertes saison a fait
une une découverte un clouage et une
double attaque
ils sont là on a gagné en trois
tactiques on ajuste activer les pièces à
fond donc on s'active à fond puis on a
fait une découverte or si j'ai pas fait
fou prend à je dirais que c'est parce
que je vais pas embarquer dans le
cavalier prend h deux tours prend d un
fou pranger quatre échecs 3b imiter tout
reprendre et 1
et là c'est carrément les blancs qui
sont devant matériellement donc on a
commencé à commencer par par fou par fou
prend un f3 prise prise prises çà çà on
a fini le développement car il ya eu 7
on a collé un petit échec bon pour voir
voulait jouer à saint caprais la clue
âge donc deuxième tactique après la
découverte le clouage et dernières
tactiques dans la double attaque
donc vous voyez il faut faire attention
à ces choses là allez on va jouer contre
de nice et après on a plus de plus de
nouveau donc n'hésitez pas à nous femmes
à me défier
là on joue contre des nids 0,06
mais voilà c'est juste pour montrer un
petit voire un rien de rien contre toi
évidemment c'est juste pour montrer un
peu comment on peut organiser partie
facilement juste en faisant attention
otago houten tactique basique un sans se
prendre la tête
alors ça pas très conseillé de la part
de dennis ladd donné il a vu échanger le
fou mais hyper un pion ils repèrent le
plan qu'il avait de plus c'est sa
structure à un peu défoncé la d'amendé 3
vient d'installer donc la difficile pour
denis ce qu'elle veut rentrer dans cette
finale
mais cette finale pour dennis années
durant et peut-être du kvk tout cas on
va juste essayé de la jouer tranquille
mettre le pion femme est on va
développer le fou ans et cinq mètres le
pion à fils aura joué solide pour le
moment mais s'est développée cavalier e
set peut-être 3f cette tour des huit
grands rock
maintenant qu'on va on va laisser faire
un en valais ces échanges et on garde
notre solidité on est solide
peut-être car il y eu quatre un peu
embêtant l'est les cavaliers e4
fourchette que j'avais pas vu moi même
donc on n'avait pas le temps de faire
bref cette île aurait pu gagner un pion
puissions rester pas mal pour nous mais
ils auraient pu nous mettre en danger
dennis on va mettre le fou en b 4 ont
essayé de jouer tranquille ou pas
prendre trop de risques
ok pour la cades va faire tour des
mythes il va faire toi on va faire à 5
comme ça on va bien protégés on aura
tout reprend détroit aussi un écomusée
j'essaie de pas bon et juste avant donné
la démission
sinon je ne veux plus jouer alors on à
thomas muxel et thomas mux thomas luxe
on va tenter un petit peu trois poisons
qui ont affaire aux trois ans premier
tech ont complètement empoisonné direct
on est solide on va voir s'il fait que
quatre pour une structure française et
pourquoi jouer une structure française
même avec le fou en b2 parce que je me
dis que peut-être le fait qu'il ait
mille cavaliers ans et 6 bat salut
affaiblit un peu le pion à le pion des
cinq jeunes peut-être pas dû prendre
direct mais bon c'est pour expliquer
l'idée tas en échange et du coup je vais
pouvoir essayer de m'installer avec un
fou en c4 pour venir gêner cinq échecs
aussi aidé à mach 6 ans à regarder
bah on va peut-être faire cavalier à 5
il a peut-être d appeler des trucs
thomas mixte
ok on va rauque et on va peut-être faire
f3 et ouvrir la position au centre taper
un peu sur le point 4 aussi je vis tu
sais bien
massie prend un air france reprend du
fou et on aura un grand mangeur et puis
on aura l'autre qui sera prêt à s'ouvrir
le roi va être un peu faible
on va voir comment on fait ça ça on a
une découpage de l'échiquier total m la
tour ans et un moment on va on va un peu
préparé notre jeu donc c'est un
éventuellement on attaque un peu le
cavalier avoir pas forcément utile
directement
ok fait dame g5 on va se débarrasser de
cette menace comme ça je suis pas sûr
soit très bien joué c'est d'y réfléchir
un peu plus longtemps
faire food et 6 normalement x 5
par quatre
d'ouvrir complètement ce centre il ya
peu sur un peu bizarre on est bien je
pense 1
donc les prix on va reprendre c'est pas
quelque chose qui me plaît pas dans ce
que j'ai fait mais m'ont collé une dame
en f3 tu vas voir c'est tranquille on me
prend dans ses sets après avoir il va
devo obligé de faire grand roque je
pense qu'on va faire dame f3 ok on
continue à accélérer à la pendule on va
lui mettre la pression bank et là on va
prendre ce qu'on récupère pas mal de
matos pour la dame deux tours pour la
dame d'avancé bien pris en plus son roi
il va pas être super bien placé
du coup j'avais doublé sur la colonne f
peut se faire qu il y ait des huit n'est
pas si bien peut-être
le nom
je pensais qu'on serait beaucoup mieux
que ça nos pièces sont un peu
désorganisé n'en est pas si bien là on
est on est même assez mal
il est même complètement raide
mais henry xaver peut-être
à commencer par h4 c'est sûr d'en
prendre un fief 3 il y aura plus près
avec dame trois échecs
elles sont pas très bien organisés pas
comment s'est passée dans le froid ça
devrait être bon dommage je crois que
j'aurais dû faire la main je croyais je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas où se trouve
à une position pas méga harmonieuse
on en est très bien autant
tiens je vais faire tous rêvent 2
j'avais pensé à ce truc pour mme attaqué
cette pièce là mais toi deux semaines
par un bon coup permet de protéger et de
ramener cette tour là-bas donc et
maintenant peut-être bec
je peux envie de faire ça j'ai pas envie
de faire ça mais bon moi qui prends des
5 g par là j'arrive pas je commence à
avoir du mal
ok heureusement qu'ils gaffe parce que
la fatigue donc je vous parle se faire
ressentir et là la position quand elle
devient trop bordélique j'arrive plus du
tout on va faire échec on va faire ça on
va refaire un autre et xhaka tempo mais
là ça va
ok on va jouer contre eux pierre maudoux
pierre de mots de mauduit pardon
excuse-moi pierre tombale mieux que sa
part adjointe aurait pu c'était
peut-être pas si loin
il a fait un truc normal une écossaise
mary énoncé testé pas mal ce que tu as
fait ça pendant décadent allemand il
faut pas parce que là la dame elle au
centre assez tôt dans la partie mais le
truc c'est que le cavalier peu plus à
chasser
donc elle est plutôt bien placé cette
dame
on a plutôt une bonne position dès la
sortie d'ouverture
ces trois ans il développe car il
afficherait fou g5 si je vais fouet
cette enverra ok donc là maintenant on
va jouer contre ce truc faible genre
fouet f4 camp rock et on va jouer contre
ce pion faible
dans des six
il est vraiment fait parce qu'il est
arriérée donc on va tout de suite tapé
dessus naturellement avec toutes nos
pièces et c'est très difficile à
défendre
pour notre adversaire ça n'est tout de
suite en grosse difficulté on va
directement le gagner
à
on va tout et l'échangé en d6 car à lyon
va le mettre sous pression on va
développer le fou crois que si on fait
tout b5 y aura peut-être à 6,6 fait car
il est 17 donc à es17 on fera peut-être
fou c4 plus tôt on mettra la tour en d1
avoir poussé quatre faudra peut-être
faire car ait lieu sans qu'on fera
peut-être f4 dans ces cas-là on preuve
il est fou c'est qu'à est fou c'est 4
après parce que foulée cinq à six fours
à quatre des cinq fois à ce succès 4 au
caire par angers 4 pourquoi pas bien
envie de lui couler un petit échec ou
pas d'ailleurs
on va faire f3 toute façon signe en f2
ça fait pas de fourchette
donc on est tranquille et s'il vient à
eux cinq on pourra peut-être faire f 4
après on va re chasser et comme ça s'il
y un an 17 on a la même position que
tout à l'heure sauf qu'on aura gagné un
tempo et s'il revient en 5 on lui fera
h3 du coup il y aura plus on arrive dans
priscilla en f2 en fera un tour ici et
son cavalier va se faire enfermer
mais on est pas mal les mecs on va faire
tour g1 est le cavalier pas très bien là
il n'est pas très heureux parce que t'as
pas trop de casse de sortie là on va
aller le cueillir man en europe où il va
le cavalier où il va le cavalier suite
allez c'est cadeau c'est pour tonton
kevin il va prendre quatre pour
ressortir en mangeant un truc qu'on va
le pré move
voilà c'est pas mal il est venu se il
est venu dans notre toile d'araignée la
toile elle est d'aider la règne à sortir
le fond ces quatre sur échec va m on va
récupérer ce qu'ils ont à faire payer
des six salles on va les changer les
pièces c'est mieux échangeons et
changement est comme ça en rentrant 17
avec la toux rauque et de façon on est
heureux d'échanger nous échanger c'est
notre leitmotiv retour en d1 de façon
sûre la colonne il pourra pas rentrer
voilà on est très heureux roi un rapt
est il va apprendre je sais pas mais s'y
prend on est heureux un final avec un
fou de plus très simple à gagner nous
sommes très heureux
oui avec le roi hockey silva de ce côté
du coup on gratte on gratte les pions en
passant par derrière
ils sont tous seuls hop une paire
honneurs par l'espagnol deux pions et on
va enlever envoyé deux pions à chaleur
pour la pop rêveuse fou de hk tâche
attention attention attention attention
s'il avait joué ses trois le pré move
aurait pu coûter cher
du coup je fais bk tu veux fermer le jeu
ces trois là on va pousser
on va de ce côté on est méchant nain
installer notre mur si comme ça avec le
renverra l'autre pions ok c'est gagner
pas mal joué quand même le nuit dit
c'était bien battus sept chats allez hop
salsa le 4 allez hop
kevin française à lenval embêtant l'usan
annonce je vais faire ces quatre mains
ce bac y aura eu une variante d'avancé
et une centaine d'années que j'ai pas
joué ça nique où on transpose enfin fou
d'être en espérant le piège on prend
tous vents des 4es et on a foulé cinq
échecs à la fin qui sait ok maintenant
il va prendre
normalement non ok il prend pas ces
trois du coup on va faire caler b5 et b6
je pense mais on prend elle s'appelle le
gambit miller baril apparemment ça
piaille ne connaît pas caché ça me
paraît très souvent beaucoup de gens et
de faire à troyes b 4 fronts dans
l'espace pas forcément très utile mais
bon bon ok il veut venir nous embêter on
vit en bessin qu'avec le cavalier
on va prendre ça je pense pas avoir joué
de la manière la plus intelligente qui
existent mais bon même sur de
l'inversion semaine entre conte la mer
dont j'ai joué mais bon j'ai pas un truc
à 3 matin je sais pas j'ai vu un grand
roque donc pour mon set chat qui joue
vraiment pas mal k s a essayé d'échanger
en ayant ce pion aux cinq pas si ça a
quelque chose on verra
c'est vraiment pas terrible ce que je
fais un pou quelle galère quelque part
secrètement j'espère que quelqu'un me
batte en fait même si je ne vous
l'avouerez jamais et que je ne vous
laisserai jamais faire via tient
aujourd'hui il ya vraiment moyen de
moyenner et tout ça non n'hésitez pas si
vous voulez jouer une partie à me défier
s'il y avait plus de défis en cours de
nouveau je veux dire
donc allez-y mais bon je sais que
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de gens sont
en tournoi en ce moment il ya beaucoup
de tournois c'est l'époque des tournois
tournoi de noël
d'autres sont en vacances
boum g4 va faire flouer 4 mais j'ai
développé ces pièces jarry maire de pas
être déjà peut-être pu prendre des cinq
mais bon j'ai envie de développer j'en
ai marre de pas être développées
tu content qu'il ait fait g4 quand même
ça me permet de caler un fou sur noir
qui l'empêchent un peu d'avancé c'est de
jouer vite main
je vais faire ce que je sais faire
accélérer
adams et 5 étoi brown est encore un pion
vers le centre et avoir une petite base
de plans et suis pas sûr soit gagnant
ainsi joue bien avec les noirs mais
remarque la plus de temps j'aurais
échangé j'aurais mis mon fou en dessin
que six pour bloquer tous les pions et
si vous ramenez l'euro ans et 8 17 et
j'aurais essayé de faire un blocus total
tour huit tours aussi c'est tout bloqué
en fait ce que là le fait qu'ils gardent
les pièces sur l'échiquier il me permet
de le jouer avec b5
ce que je veux dire très bientôt faire
lui même le faire tout de suite en fait
dès 5h ce sur fou prend g2g d'armes
français 8 et puis on prend à 6 c'est
exactement ce que je vais faire la
découverte ne passe pas voilà maintenant
c'est fini
l'encaissé tour de - f c'est élémentaire
mais je pense que même jusque là ils
pouvaient encore il aurait encore pu
échanger je pense essayer de tenir
marche pas ci fais ça aussi fait genre
fou 17 pour essayer de couvrir les
poussées de pion est bloqué parce que
j'ai tout sur noir bon pas sûr que c'est
du marché mais possible parfois ça
marche ça de fou et enfin le bloquer
puisqu'il ya plus de pousser plus de
rupture pour empêcher l'armée à tour ses
8 après tour ses six tours ces huit
étuis tient coi je touche plus à rien et
tu tiens ça aurait plus tentés
ça aurait pu tenter alors maintenant la
groucha allegro chats eux quatre larry
beechey son nom de quelle cadence 3 ou 3
2 comme tu veux comme ça t'arrange
content et on va refaire un gambit de là
on a déjà utilisé contre contre le chat
contre les gens qui jouent contre les
abonnés je sais qu'il n'aime pas trop
jouer contre cette ouverture le pion qui
vient de côté grâce pas mal ça nous a
permis d'échanger un pion b contre un
pion des plutôt bien fou des trois jeux
séparés ce projet de manière originale
du tout convaincu par mon jeu
là n'est pas la question de faire de
sacré merdes déjà qui avait déjà battu
en plus mais il pourrait me rebattre
puis je disais là aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment le jour où vous pouvez le faire
quoi you can do it qua non une te dire
yes we can coiffe notamment des clous et
ce truc là
teheran le jour où fo qui en l1 entre
vous qu'ils fassent l'exploit record
c'est possible
je souffre là pour le moment c'est à
dire souffre à la
souffre adam ces pièces mal placé mais
bon ok je suis encore dans le truc quoi
ces quatre je vais revenir avec le cas
échéant pas où je vais me battre
darcy fébé singes farc a aidé ici c'est
puis je vais jouer filet de ce côté là
en fait tu vas l'attaqué quand un
bourrin je pense donc accueilli des
quatre peut-être pas mal joué donc on va
prendre une fois là on va faire à trois
on va quand même chassé le cavale parle
on peut peut-être gagner un pion en fait
on repérera du matos de l'autre côté
chez palinges comment ils commençaient à
part à trois je sais pas j'ai pas envie
de laisser du cac et prend ses deux ça
me saoule j'avais partir là bas
tv5 quand même waouh j'aime bien il a du
panache alors sur caravane des six
ok on va voir ce que ça donne parce
qu'en fait il fait qu'elle prend ces
deux cas les français 8 et sur quel
point je prend 2,7 sur échec n'est sûr
fou prend des six je prends et quand il
prend je prends donc et c'est eux qui
les france élite pour refaire tours
france et 8 mai je bougerais matour il
pourra faire dame prend 1,5 et d'amd
deux essais pas dit que soit mieux un
poil de chance que je t'assure qu'il est
tout calculer mais c'est le pas d'un
fils et le panache parce qu'elle prend 1
dames français ça tout il y aussi en
plus simple mais bon quel point cette
dame croit ça m'a suffit en fait le truc
c'est quand tu calcules une une variante
qui gagne globe ça suffit largement de
une variante qui gagne suffit pas obligé
d'en calculer une deuxième avec un
défilé aujourd'hui ça si je réussis à ne
pas en perdre c'est un exploit
je pense que l'inde est un des auditeurs
valoir me battre on espère on espère
mais là je pense que c'est pas la
meilleure version en fait le tempo ça
jusque là j'ai vu
ok et on va échanger les dames et on va
se retrouver avec une pièce de plus on
va faire le beau jeune homme après move
to reprend à 7 en espérant qu'ils aient
pas de peau de banane
on essaye de jouer vite comme ça un
maximum de joueurs peuvent passer
ok vous ces 5
mais bon c'est aussi le beau jeu de
prêts nous mettrons des risques c'est
marrant
qu'est ce que je faisais au portugal moi
même sans vacances en fait taper le pion
là ça on va aller mater s'alluma
bitstream jackman bitstream
c'est quoi ton pseudo d'ailleurs sûr sur
youtube et du coup tours et huit matches
difficiles à éviter
c'est cool parce qu'on défend enfin les
deux tourelles peuvent plus intervenir
en défense et nous on a notre fou qui
défend f26 jamais donc on est vraiment
très solide c'est celui que je crois
mais en fait je suis pas du tout sûr je
serai sûr j'ai pas de support à mes
créations sur le pacs ne suis pas que
les gens connaissent son construction
discorde il en réfère toujours recette
on va s'en prendre aux plongées 7 qui
n'est plus défendable
c'est quoi un clou on joue avec les gens
et en somme on profite de ma fatigue
pour essayer de me battre
ok on va mater comme ça avec
l'intervention du fou c5 qui servait à
mater en contrôlant la case f8 ne nous
est pas vouloir laisser chercher mais
bon allez on va jouer contre richesse
mais sinon un lift assure en plus quand
quand je fais des lives sinon madeline
string je suis juste j'ai juste la tête
qui vient de son art la tête qui est une
machine à laver en fait j'ai
l'impression de céder à turin sur un
système informatique et que ça ça bug en
fait et quand je suis fatigué comme ça
bizarrement le seul truc que je peux
faire part bizarrement ou pas s'est joué
aux échecs en fait c'est le seul truc où
mon cerveau marche encore à moitié
marc enfin marrant
écrivant écrit moi sur sur le maçon et
d'histoire t'inquiète pas je ne vais pas
je n'ai pas être divulgués ton ton
pseudo donc l'abreuvement on l'est on
laisse prendre des 5 1 c'est pas très
bon on voit alors la jouer 24 heures
lors dorique comment j'ai juste pas
envie surtout pendant le chant fin tu
vois si je compare 24 d'affilée où
regarder le championnat du monde de
rapide bon champion du monde de rapide
passe avant c'est quand même c'était
quand même un championnat du monde ici
pense qu'on va passer une belle une
belle une belle après-midi ans enfin je
sais pas vous mais en tout cas je pense
que là les trois journées et puis en
plus je suis toujours content d'avoir ça
en replay sur la chaîne presque - sur la
chaîne glisse stream boom tu vas
championnat du monde rapide
enfin pas ta les trois journées du truc
quoi enfin je trouve que c'est beau non
après je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
mais moi ça me fait plaisir je vous dis
tiens maintien on a réussi à faire ça
puis on partageait encore un peu notre
passion du jeu d'échecs avec les gens
mais ça c'est cool tu as ta maison tu
dis bon ma faim à tuer si je le faisais
pas enfin personne le frais et donc du
coup ça fait plaise que voilà qu'on
puisse puisse participer quelque part à
à partager ce qu'on aime
j'aurais tout fait en fait on a réussi à
jouer un gambit dame sans avoir eu à
protéger le pion des 5 5 c'était
peut-être pas top
peut-être dû faire autre chose mais oh
mais sans avoir eu on n'a pas eu à jouer
de 6 dont on a joué cinq direct on a
fait le fier enquête au mail on a gagné
en un temps où de quelque part on
continue à jouer tempo continue à mettre
la pression sur les pendules à ce pont
du las un champion du monde
c'est sympa oui
du coup
demi-fou king shelby qui est content
ok donc empêche cavaliers à cinq et vit
de lui faire à 6 bon je me rase pas b5
tout de suite mais je vais me n'a cédé
que je vais bouger le fou
j'ai cinq ans à lyon va le chasser
qui avait fait reprise prise il va
reprendre ok on est très content et ça
c'est un truc à ne jamais faire ch pas
si vous savez mais normalement à moins
de raisons claires et précises et changé
deux pièces contre une tour est un pion
ça ne jamais faire faut le savoir c'est
important développe on développe ici
fait qu'ils allaient descendre à faire
damer vii
on va continuer à chasser avec la tour
ici face de la dame
ok on va faire pousser car l'idée sexy
fait tout re en un cavalier ces deux et
on gagne une calèche et si fait tour des
ans la cavalière deux échecs cavaliers
pros eux deux tours prend des airs maths
quand je vous disais que mon cerveau le
seul truc qui pouvait faire c'était
jouer aux échecs voyez même des
tactiques comme ça a complètement crevé
ça marche encore
voilà ça le truc il est cagoulé capable
de se concentrer
alors ces trois plus trois et cinq
puissances ici chacun est la tour c'est
plutôt 4,5 points et on comprend là sur
échec on prend là et on se retrouve avec
donc en adam de +4 encore un pion au
passage un ça mange pas de pain gratter
des pions s'écoule bon comment fini ça
c'est juste avant pas d'imagination là
est exact on devient un kick en finale
c'est pour ça aussi que les deux pièces
mineurs en milieu milieu je sais plus
fort mais même en finalement c'est plus
fort après tu as le concept des pions
des pions passer des trucs des machins
je me suis auto cloué comme une merde on
va chasser à chasser
on va faire caillasser 4 voilà je galère
et une dame de plus mais c'est vraiment
question de cerveau est en bouillie et
mon manque de motivation aussi vous
savez jouer des positions comme ça c'est
normalement c'est ça m'arrive pas quoi
il ne veut pas très envie de la jouer
d'un côté moi plus je la joue longtemps
puis ça m'avantage jeu je vais laisser
tourner ma pendule d'ailleurs ça me fera
moins deux parties sur les moins de
chance de perdre très intéressant comme
concept
dommage dommage ouvrage qui l'a
abandonné à laura smet ont méga danger
on va jouer le contre captain tout était
ok maître fide on est un peu on est un
peu dans la merde spectre est quelqu'un
que je connaisse on est un peu dans la
merde à maître fide quand même je ne
pense pas pour la gagne est ok mais si
demain tu écris que le champ de mines de
rapides barace du commandant 21h en
trois jours charenton cerveau
c'est-à-dire un peu de la bouillie mais
ok mais prenez le pion quand même quoi
les mecs je leur donne un pion personne
n'en veut allez hop ça c'est bien quoi
au moins on s'amuse 1
tu es mon capitaine de tt devrait
devrait pouvoir faire quelque chose
quand même là on espère on espère enfin
on se mit espère
nous étions là on va jouer pour le monde
modestement quand même à ce qu'il est
prend des quatre qui évidemment ça
allait pas passer alors avec le fond ces
sept on va jouer à la bourrin d'amd
d'amd si je ne veux faire crisser 4 mais
peut-être que dante saint caprais dans
la foulée ok on va essayer moi je
consomme en 5,5 j'aurais préféré le
jouer dans une carence plus court sa
mort est favorisée
ok alors sur cinq cavaliers ces cas
d'anne 17 et prend 1,5 et prend 1,5
puis on prend un sens qu'on va mettre la
tour en des huit préparé tous à mettre
la pression sur cette colonne on va
attaquer comme des brutes on n'a pas
trop le choix si on veut gagner faut
mater de façon maintenant sur re5
prendrait savent pas grand-chose bon en
fera s'y sont essayé de pousser b5
pour se retrouver dans la merde là quand
même assez bien cependant un petit à
petit regard mettre la dame en d5
mais c'est trop de provoquer ces cartes
au québec quatre maintenant donc je ne
sais pas du tout comment attaquer on va
faire tour c'est 8
[Musique]
on a un temps de retard pour faire le
truc avec un pion prends tu comprends
qu'à et b4 si on prend fourrage de l'on
perd trop de matos malheureusement on va
prendre comme ça on va remettre galles
et en os est là on est très mal là on
est très mal mais ok enfin point fois
qu'on va arnaqué une position sur
l'arnaqué
on va quand même essayer
comment ça se remarque cette merde
bloqués s'il fait g4 on va sacrifier on
essaiera mais je crois qu'on va devoir
perdre des mecs la région un mec à 2003
on avait gagné la semaine dernière cette
semaine la place accrue même le fonds va
garder le cavale on va essayer
ok fou
qui est jusque là je pensais qu'il
allait faire ça et maintenant prem's et
qu'on a du mal à créer une menace en
fait
on va prendre là il va apprendre de la
tour on va faire d'amd 4 mai comme ça va
commencer à récupérer du matos on va
rester derrière mais on aura récupéré un
petit truc peut-être un peu plus chaud
que ça ne l'était il ya deux trois coups
on reprend fauqué on va pas dire qu'on
reprend la confiance non reprend espoir
certaines de ttk peut-être était un poil
gourmand après la prise de la pièce a
voulu aller nous raser et tourcoing u6
c'est bien joué parce que surtout pas me
prendre la caisse est malin
c'est malin
une telle ambition qu'il faut prendre ça
peut-être complètement con c'est être
complètement débile j'arrive pas
calculer un coeur à prendre prendre
il va prendre pour apprendre là et
surtout racette
on va donc il va faire un échec
en premier et on va prendre des gardes
et peut-être un père pète mais j'ai pu
oublier de calcul est entre guillemets
ça on empêche le mat angers7
vraiment on va se faire mater h 2 bien
vu bien vu refuser bien que calcul était
dur ouais c'était joli la fin c'était
joli on va abandonner joli match on
aurait dû dans ce cas là peut-être ici
ouais on pouvait pas on pouvait pas on
pouvait pas faire nul belle victoire
d'anne 17 bien joué bien je vais d'abord
tout vent je n'ai pas vu ce matin à
l'elysée c'était difficile c'était
difficile mais c'était une partie
marrante ché pa ys y en eut bien jouer
quoi bravo à toi ton ton joli mat avec
le tour e 1 et le match là bas c'était
assez sympa c'est assez vous bien joué
allez on va prendre le suivant m'ont
finalement on a perdu une quelque part
tant mieux quelque part j'ai envie de
dire tant mieux c'était une partie très
sympa on joue contre eux avaient 8 alors
rejoint notre truc avec ses 6
mac 128 millions pour seat et bafouille
c'est complètement nul ne surtout pas
jouer ça c'est une très mauvaise
ouverture c'est pas parce que je le joue
que c'est bon ça ne veut rien dire
maintenant qu'il est comme ça
tranquillement
bon alors
voyons voyons ce que la belle warocqué
ou pas faire dans ma 5 d'un machin qui
va les mater dernier c'était sympa je
vais pas loin c'est presque revenu il
faut g4 les machins
j'ai peut-être dû prendre en bd en
premier ont des seins et faire un nom
donc on va faire petit rock on va
prendre prendre les retours ses huîtres
ou des quatre cavaliers dessin ok parce
qu'on peut
c'est ça un peu attaqué on va voir si on
adversaire peut éventuellement nous
finir possible possible
c'est sain peut attaquer on verra ce que
ça va c'est plus marrant c'est plus fun
c'est beaucoup plus fun et des 4 5 et ou
revenir l'attaqué à fond
on va voir on va voir comment apple s'en
sort
bon
on va faire tes idées cattrall et
sacrifiant ses 3
sur un adversaire de renom il a du mal à
bellevue 8 qui revient à angers 5 avec
le fou c'est un aveu d'échec et nous dit
qu'on va les lui sacrifiant ces trois-là
cesser écrit qu'on va faire tout
français 3,6 fait grand roque on va
faire tout reprend pions prend vous
prend et on fera d'un match par d'un bep
de match vous allez voir je pense que
roy f1 c'est son meilleur coup on va
quand même faire tout repenser 3 pendant
ces 3 on ira voir si on prend un médecin
de 45 chez pas on reste battre à fond ne
pas oublier aussi que ça ça peut être en
prise un jour mais là il paraît très mal
abel bits donc échoué un bar un boom
on va tomber
il va tomber mais c'est sûr qu'il va
tomber
[Musique]
il est par là pas le meilleur coup mais
bon
donc émis à dure ajoute tendre ou pas ce
que je fais n'importe quoi il ya ces
trois maintenant tout est bon pour se
reconcentrer pour gagner cette partie
une deuxième fois ce que je déteste
avoir affaire à une partie d'échecs deux
fois c'est pas une bonne chose a déjà
gagné une fois on parle à gagner une
deuxième fois mais bon fallait mieux se
concentrer bon on attaque la dame va
faire qu'il prend avec trois maintenant
comme ça on va menacer de gagner ça qui
va nous permettre de gagner ça là bas
vont apprendre ça il va prendre on va
prendre les bons ça me permet de
liquider du matos on va pouvoir remettre
nos pièces en place mais c'est toujours
été loin
ça on sait sécuriser le roi et on va
pouvoir jouer plus tranquillement bon ça
c'était un peu de la merde qu'est ce que
je veux qu'ils ont là bas on ne va pas
lui laisser gagner à cet échange et
échanger et changer ton don hay tombe
pas mais bon ton dans le piège tombe
tombe donc il n'est pas tombé la bande
et regarde le comte ricou à l'oreille
faire re cat rie coup le 6 déc attend à
lui échangé là on va lui faire cavalier
f3 food et 3 alors ce qui vaut ce petit
ricou soit 70,8
je vais vital et riku cavagnoud 7 alors
oui couveuse jouer avec fauve 5 mais il
n'a pas développé son fou qu'il aurait
dû mettre en d6 alors on va essayer de
l'embêter ricoux on va jouer fouet f4
j'aime la sortie lecavalier en premier
on va essayer de jouer sur le fait que
qu'il ait oublié de sortir le fou pour
l'embêter sa 58e exactement aurait
peut-être pu faire d'essais mais bon ok
on va jouer tranquille juste et s'est
joué sur le fait que son cavalier mal
placé voir comment il va se débrouiller
je connais un peu riku et donc je sais
comment l'embêter et on va voir comment
il règle ses soucis montrons ici on lui
crée une pure isolé on va jouer du
cavalier baidoa s'il reprend pas on va
jouer b4 on va consolider le pion on va
essayer de rester avec notre pion de
plus en c5 et tous les problèmes
rubrique ou pas à part du problème qui
n'a pas commencé par food et 6 et
décider si ça peut aller oui oui ça
aurait pu aller mais bon j'essaie de
poser des problèmes à faire km/h
inquiets des quatre mais un problème
c'est que maintenant l'option de plus
maintenant on a pu en plus cavalier pas
très stable sur dame ces deux il n'y
aura pas trop de cases
on est on est quand même bien petit à
petit on augmente la pression khk de
mettre force et on va pouvoir échanger
les pièces on va remettre un cavalier en
d4 petit à petit les adwares fac et h4
on va faire prise il va faire prison
affaire qui est des cartes on va
échanger les pièces et petit à petit va
en avoir de moins en moins sur
l'échiquier sera de plus en plus facile
entre guillemets de hockey lah il n'a
pas vu la pièce en un coup mais c'est
parce que la position était déjà
difficile
puis les positions sont sûrs plus il est
facile de rater ce genre de choses on va
essayer de se venger sur le pion mais on
fera autour d un tranquille on voit même
pas ré attaquer le fou à l'essence et
trois ans l'attaquera plus tard
on est pas mal on est pas mal les mecs
on est prend-il
le pépin vous pouvez regarder la
dernière journée des championnats du
monde au rythme où là je fais tourner un
tempo c'est tellement sur qui les prend
dans ses 3 mais bon tour des seins quand
même bien joué dans tous les cas donc
tous les cas c'est par un mauvais coup
c'est un coup de placement on va faire
feu dame prend fou en accélère un peu la
cadence pour essayer de faire passer
maximum de joueurs il restera 2 2 défi
on n'aura pas tous le temps de passer
quelle est ma cadence préféré sur
internet 3 0 ou 3 + 2 mais sinon à la
carence acajou et le must est 15 plus 10
[Musique]
bizarrement c'était pas lui ce parce que
j'ai besoin d'un peu de temps vous avez
remarqué je suis souvent mal autant j'ai
besoin d'un peu de temps à prendre de
l'adamaoua jouer sur le pion des cinq
faible avec la pièce de plus ça devrait
le faire
on a quand même très bien rien pompeux
et changer les dames parce qu'on est un
avantage matériel là me 5 en plus on
protège le pion il va faire d'alger et 6
c'était sûr on va mettre la tour au 1
place les pièces
évidemment j'aurais peut-être un petit h
3 pour éviter tous les maths
donc il doit jouer cette finale n'a pas
mettre la tour en e2 pour tous blindé à
tour en 3 pour blinder sa une amnésie
son affaire h3 y affaire d'âme ses dons
a fait retour des deux comme ça on va
blindés toutes les cases proche du roi
proche des pions parlons sur les pions
enfin je crois un de la tour en d2 vous
à tous sera protégé et puis après on
réfléchir à comment comment avancer
protège toutes les pièces ok ça c'est
pas grave on est la tour ans est roi on
va aller le récupérer avec un réussir à
nous grimpions il aurait quand même pu
nous gratter un pion mais bon il nous
serait resté le pion b ça vous aurait
suffi d'un parent adjoint éric où il
s'est bien battu on va jouer contre
les ducs de normandie ça va un moment
qu'ils proposent et on va lui faire 4 on
va rejouer notre gambie de l'ale elle
gagne fidèles elle encaissé 14 c'est pas
le truc le plus les contrevenants bykov
tu me donnes un pion n'ont jamais je ne
prendrai trompions décalage les pions
c'est de la merde c'est un peu ce mini
duc de normandie
mais bon il va avoir du mal le duc
je veux détrôner le duc tonton est ce
que tu veux détrôner le duc
je pense qu'elle doit longer 8 6 1 6 3
en g8 c'est s'il vient là il sera
enfermé ci viendra y serait enfermée
terme ou des gages à ce fantastique
c'est génial non mais j'adore c'est très
conceptuel dit dégage c'est génial c'est
génial il appliquait quasiment que des
coups de cavaliers j'adore je suis
complètement fan de ce début de partie
c'est tellement dans l'esprit c'est trop
dans l'esprit même ses consultants
allemands au dessus faire cailler des
six matchs va me suivre je suis trop
heureux
qui tombait dans le trou quoi
complètement quoi du qui échangent
c'est génial
j'ai trop envie de mater angers 6
maintenant enfin je ne peux plus quoi
parfois je vois des idées de match je
n'y arrive plus quoi en discussion il
s'est fié rapide on aura encore deux
parties éventuellement non ce marasme
ans le prévenu
complètement raté je voulais pas du tout
prêt move ça ça a cliqué tout seul
or quelle horreur bon maintenant on a
une dame de moins contre le duc bon
alors est-ce qu'on va quand même alors
le duc c'est toi c'est toi conte moi un
v1 asie vient prendre l'option vas-y
bien aller le duc
c'est chaud c'est chaud c'est chaud com
- ses fans au moins ses fans je suis
très heureux de ce mystique bon et le
duc s'est pas fait je dis que c'est pas
fait ce qui est tellement une poubelle
j'ai envie de dire même avec sa dame de
plus c'est pas si simple
on va vraiment des grosses poubelles
quand tu viens tu gagnes du matos et pas
forcément si simple après à gagner se
bat bien
du coup c'est très drôle dont il va
réussir à s'en sortir le duc ou pas il a
plus de temps à les fonds de jouer à la
pendule non là on a vraiment le droit de
le faire tomber quand même parce qu'il a
eu un un avantage certain dans son a
toujours le droit de faire tomber
graviano missclick il a quand même ça
quand même bien avantagé
et j'ai pas envie de lui prendre le
cavalier ce que j'allais lui faire
perdre du temps là ils devaient se dire
que je prenant ses six ans et huit en
fait et la cheville il obligé de mettre
à jour sa pensée ok la fois être un peu
vicelard faut jouer des coups qui
paraissent un peu bizarre mais qui sont
pas mauvais ok mais du coup un on prend
il doit prendre de la tour on va prendre
un set
du coup avec nos coûts un peu malin
alors on se retrouve avec avantages
matériels
leduc qui a voulu simplifier mais il a
oublié qu'il avait perdu trop de matos
et le tos ma du duc qui est en train de
crouler et on va monter le roi et on a
réussi à le battre quand même l'algérie
contre le bo je tiens bien faire le beau
genre à jouer conclut le beau jeu
c'était chaud c'était chaud leduc à des
proches d'eux de nous battre il était
vraiment pas loin s candidat s b qu'à
pousser le beau jeu
[Musique]
lp/o les touts les gambie à la con sont
de sortie l eau du cap il se prend pas
se prendre la peau de banane mais je la
sentais bien la peau de banane un
sérieux j'étais confiant je tends
confiante utah en confiance
la pollution du duke était tellement
pourri qu'elle n'était pas facile à
jouer il était mal autant et tout donc
c'est pas étonnant quelque part qu'il
ait fini par par la perdre
quel beau jeu on joue vite comme ça on
va lui pourrir sa structure où l'unique
et sa structure comme vous voulez
pousser à fond pas si c'est bon donc on
a foi 3.986 jamais je passe sur soi très
intelligent avoir fait ça mais bon c'est
dans l'esprit comme ils s'appellent le
beau jeu ça donne envie de faire le beau
jeu vous voyez
pour
le beau jeu bout rxh et le foot
bah c'est le beau jeu de partout il fait
le beau jeu je fais le beau jeu c'est
une belle partie où j'ai failli faire
d'amd 2ème prendre une méga fourchette à
boom des à mince des cats il va prendre
longtemps à prendre ici on a affaire
d'âme des deux ayant il fait du très
beau jeu c'est tendu s'est tendue ces
temps de cette partie ce sera je pense
la dernière du stream
malheureusement pour les autres
personnes qui ont fait des demandes aux
deux parties sera pour la prochaine fois
désolé les mecs un peu après chance vous
pouvez comprendre après les championnats
du monde étouffe pas envie de faire des
autres des heures sup de jeu même si le
jeu est beau frère le serviteur est un
peu fatigué l'esprit do dessus du beau
jeu
tout est tout feu d'esprit est au dessus
de tous mes dessins
je sais pas je veux du tout là ce que je
fais j'ai l'impression que c'est
complètement pipeau mais bon on avance
on avance on avance on avance et lobo je
résiste à 10 résiste résiste boom ces
quatre salles en raison des dominés par
le beau jeu coiffe
je sens qu'on n'est pas super bien le
déteste ma position aucun a tenté de la
finale c'est pas du tout bouge
c'est ne pas jouer deux finales le beau
jeu quoi non mais il est au dessus de
nous quand on n'y peut rien voir mais
qui est plus fort sur cette partie ah je
suis pas du tout sûr que c'était une
bonne idée de prendre ça encore que non
ça va en fait excuses le beau jeu tu
avais raison
c'était bien joué c'était bien joué bon
allez c'est chaud c'est chaud c'est
chaud on a encore la tête on va lui
faire c'est 5 et où c'est chaud on va
finir sur une partie serrée mais je
pense que c'est quoi la cadence a séduit
3 2 dommage
gaymard l'otan a fait 3-0 mais bon on
veut faire ces cinq dames des cinq dames
prend 17 ou un truc du style mais on
aura tous rêvent 7 et où et quand même
pas faire dame c6 espèce de double
attaque
il va faire tomber 8 ont à faire c'est
ça qu'on va commencer à le fuite alors
fermé sur la côte est en train de
prendre le dessus et comme ça prouve
hélas radâmes des cinq dames prend ok
mais on fait quand même ces cinq comme
ça ça nous permettra d'obtenir dam des
cinq échecs
ok on va chasser je ne veux pas laisser
la dame ici je suis pas du tout
intéressés par cette dame
ok on va chasser
repoussés on va on va faire ça comme ça
ça on a nos options là bas là je la sens
bien parce que nos deux pions ils sont
ils sont frais ok il pouvait pas gagner
v6 grâce à tour prend des quatre mais
nos deux pions il était hope est bien
soutenue par le fou g2 est ensemble
voulais faire c'est cette des sept des
huit et on est bon les tontons comme ça
on finit sur une victoire
c'était chaud c'était chaud on va
pousser pousser ses sets ça ce ne peut
pas jouer là bas il peut pas jouer le
clouage parce qu'on fait ça en fin de
course et là on va il ya tout qui gagne
on va comme ça
et hop c'est un peu ce qu'on voulait
faire deux pas de soissons avec les deux
pions les envoyer comme ça et hop une
dame et hop
deux dames ben tout d'un coup on a des
dames dame dès 8 heures
la tour qui est cloué
ok le beau jeu c'est de mater avec la
dernière tour qui monte espèce de
trident est bon ça aurait été sympa
merci au beau jeu d'avoir joué c'était
sympa j'espère que le stream vous a plu
moi en tout cas c'est st marc en a fini
par en perdre une et tant mieux
et ouais je vous dis et je vous dis à
bientôt
ciao ciao